All right. So, today we're going to talk
about someone whose ideas have really
shaken things up in the world of health
for a long, long time. Dr. Joel Wallik.
He started out as a veterinarian. And
let me tell you, his message is, well,
it's provocative. His claims are
incredibly bold. And the whole thing,
his entire theory kicks off with one
really shocking observation. So, Dr.
Wallik basically puts his entire
argument into one big question. He asks,
"Hey, if you want to live a long,
healthy life, are medical doctors really
the people you should be listening to?"
And his answer, it's a hard no. And
believe me, he's got some pretty
startling numbers to back up why he
thinks that way. This right here, this
is the statistic that pretty much kicked
off his famous lecture series. According
to Wallik, the average MD, you know, a
medical doctor, dies at just 58 years
old. That's almost 18 years younger than
the average American. Now, for him, that
wasn't just some weird interesting fact.
No, to him, it was proof. Solid evidence
that there's a huge fundamental flaw in
how we think about health. And to really
build his case, Wallak often points to a
claim that 300,000 Americans die every
single year from medical negligence. I
mean, think about that number. For him,
it represents a system that's not just
failing to make us live longer, it's
actually making our lives shorter. So,
if that's the problem he's pointing to,
where on earth did he find the solution?
Well, the answer, and really the origin
of his entire way of thinking, it all
started on a family farm back in
Missouri. And the big insight, it didn't
come from a fancy hospital. Nope, it
came from the barn. So, picture this.
Young Joel Wallak is growing up on a
beef farm, and he starts noticing
something. Something that just doesn't
quite make sense. His family, they're
raising all their own feed for the
calves. you know, corn, soybeans, hay,
but they were always adding this extra
stuff to what the animals ate. And
that's where the contradiction was.
You've got these cals, right? They're
headed to market in just 6 months, and
their feed is packed, absolutely
fortified with vitamins, minerals, and
trace minerals. But then you have the
family hoping to live to be 100, and
they're eating the same farm fresh food,
but with none of that extra
supplementation. Kind of weird, right?
So naturally, he asked his dad about it.
You know, hey, why do the cows get all
this extra stuff and we don't? And the
answer he got was just classic Missouri
farm wisdom. His dad basically told him,
"Shut up, boy, and just be happy you're
getting this good farm fresh food." The
whole idea of supplementing a person's
diet, it just wasn't even on the radar.
It wasn't until he got to veterinary
school that the light bulb finally went
on for Wallik. He realized why. See, the
livestock industry uses nutrition to
prevent disease for one simple reason.
It's cheaper. I mean, think about it.
There's no major medical insurance for
cows. To actually make a profit, farmers
have to use the most efficient,
cost-effective way to keep their animals
healthy. And that way is nutrition, not
a bunch of expensive surgeries and
treatments. So, that insight he got from
the farm, that became the absolute
foundation for his entire theory on
human health. And it's all built around
a very specific set of nutrients that he
argues are absolutely essential for
life. And what's that magic number? It's
90. According to Dr. Wallik, every
single day your body needs 9090
essential nutrients to function, to
maintain itself, and to repair itself.
And if you don't get them, if you fall
short, you are, in his own words, going
to get a deficiency disease. So what
exactly are these 90 nutrients? Well,
Wallock breaks them down into four aman
groups. You've got 60 minerals, 16
vitamins, 12 essential amino acids, you
know, the building blocks for protein,
and three essential fatty acids. His
whole argument is that if you can get
all of these into your system, you're
basically giving your body all the tools
it needs to just thrive. And this idea,
this leads to probably his biggest, most
controversial claim of all. He says that
based on his work, and he did thousands
of autopsies on both animals and humans,
he came to one conclusion. Any animal or
human who dies of so-called natural
causes actually died from a nutritional
deficiency. Okay, so how does this whole
theory actually apply in the real world?
Well, Wallak argues that a ton of the
most common diseases that we see all
around us, they're not what we've been
told they are. He has a different name
for them, deficiency diseases. From his
perspective, all these conditions we
treat with expensive drugs and
surgeries, they're really just the
body's way of screaming that it's
missing a key raw material. And he's got
a lot of examples he uses to make his
point. Let's take copper for example.
Wallik claims the very first sign of a
copper deficiency is gray hair. Then it
keeps going. You get wrinkles because
the elastic fibers in your skin start
breaking down. Then you get varicose
veins. And it can end with something as
serious as a fatal ruptured aneurysm.
And all of that, he says, comes from a
lack of one single simple trace mineral.
Or how about calcium? Yeah, we all think
strong bones, right? But Wallik connects
a calcium deficiency to a huge list of
common health issues. We're not just
talking osteoporosis. He's talking about
things like 85% of low back pain, high
blood pressure, muscle cramps, kidney
stones, even the awful symptoms of PMS.
He also loves to challenge these
longheld medical beliefs like ulcers. He
points out that for decades
veterinarians knew that ulcers and PEGs
were caused by a bacteria and you could
treat it with the mineral bismouth. Now
eventually the National Institutes of
Health confirmed a similar cause in
humans. But Wallik argues that the old
myth that stress causes ulcers just
won't die. One of his most powerful
examples though has to do with selenium.
There's this fatal heart condition. It's
called cardiomyopathy or quan disease.
And it used to be a huge problem in
certain parts of China where the soil
had absolutely no selenium in it. So
according to the theory, what happened
when they started giving the population
selenium supplements? The disease just
vanished. Okay. So if these 90 nutrients
are so essential and not having them is
so dangerous, that leads to a really big
question, right? Why on earth aren't we
just getting them from the food we eat?
And this right here is the final piece
of the puzzle in Wallik's whole theory.
He says it's not really about eating the
wrong foods. The problem is that the
food itself is fundamentally broken. His
core argument is pretty simple. He says
that for more than 100 years, our modern
farming practices have stripped our
soils of all the good stuff, all those
essential minerals. And what that means
is that the crops, the fruits, the
vegetables, everything that's grown in
that depleted soil is also missing those
minerals. The logic here is actually
super simple when you think about it.
Plants can make things like vitamins and
amino acids, but they can't just create
minerals out of thin air. They can't
manufacture copper or selenium or
calcium. They have to pull them up from
the soil through their roots. So, if the
minerals aren't in the soil in the first
place, there's no way they can be in the
food we eat. Simple as that. And that of
course leads us to the grand finale of
his theory. If you can't get these
essential nutrients from your food
because the soil is empty, then taking
supplements isn't just a nice little
health hack. In his view, it's
absolutely essential if you want to
prevent and even reverse these so-called
deficiency diseases. So, we're left with
this really huge question that basically
challenges everything we think we know
about food and medicine. If our food
supply is missing the fundamental
building blocks of life, then what is
the true foundation of health? It's a
really compelling theory for sure. If
this has got you thinking, get with the
person who shared this video with you
for more information. Or you can contact
a certified holistic health coach today
by going to www.dailywithdoc.com.